[Musique]
bonsoir le journal de tv soixante dix
huit pour l'essentiel de l'actualité
locale du jour bienvenue dans cette
édition les titres de ce jeudi 5 mars
confirmée de coronavirus dans les
yvelines il s'agit d'un homme habitant
de versailles relativement âgées d'après
les informations de la préfecture à la
personne a été hospitalisée à paris pas
d'explication pour le moment sur les
origines de la contamination
malgré le désistement de plusieurs
équipes et l'épidémie ducobu 19 le paris
nice est toujours maintenue départ de la
course cycliste programmé dimanche
depuis les yvelines présentation des
deux premières étapes à plaisir et
chevreuse et puis les dernières
informations des élections municipales
premier tour le 15 mars à suivre des
reportages lors des campagnes de pierre
déjean à montigny le bretonneux de
béatrice pira voisins le bretonneux nous
parlerons également de loulou lutte
ouvrière qui a investi huit candidats
dont le département et on commence tout
de suite avec l'actualité du jour elle
les yvelines touchés à leur tour par le
coronavirus un premier cas décelés hier
nous a été confirmée aujourd'hui par les
services de l'état est la personne
concernée est un homme habitant de
versailles retraités d'après les
informations communiquées par la
préfecture
il a été transféré dans un hôpital
parisien l' agence régionale de santé
enquête pour comprendre les origines de
la contamination le patient ne revient
pas d'une zone à risque comme la chine
ou le nord de l'italie
son entourage a reçu des masques de
protection et sera en confinement
pendant une période de 14 jours
pas de mesures spécifiques à ce jour
mise en place sur le territoire la
préfecture tient à rassurer il s'agit
d'un cas isolé est les yvelines ne sont
pas un foyer épidémique il y a quelques
jours déjà le président du conseil
départemental n'était pas alarmiste au
micro de michael et demi d'euros je
pense qu'il faut rassurer nos
concitoyens
c'est une épidémie mais c'est pas la
grippe espagnole
de l'avant-guerre bon il ya un danger
mais le danger surtout pour des
personnes déjà malades et affaiblis donc
pas de panique
mais après les structures de santé
publique en france sont anciennes et
solide
on peut leur faire confiance du moins je
le pense françois de mazières maire de
versailles s'est entretenu aujourd'hui
de son côté avec le directeur de
l'hôpital andré mignot à propos de ce
premier cas un dispositif est mis en
place à compter de ce jour au centre
hospitalier de versailles pour la prise
en charge d'éventuels nouvelles
personnes contaminées et versailles où
d'après les informations de nos
confrères d'actu 78 en deuxième cas
suspect celui d'une mère de famille a
été signalée ce jeudi en france le
coronavirus a fait six morts à l'heure
où je vous parle 377 cas ont été
confirmés dans l'hexagone
rappelons qu'il existe des gestes
simples pour lutter contre la
propagation du coty koffi 19 mais aussi
des autres virus
le premier de ces gestes et de se laver
les mains régulièrement une solution
hydro alcoolique peut être utilisé en
complément tousser et éternuer dans
votre coude utiliser des mouchoirs à
usage unique il est jeté ensuite enfin
si vous êtes malade il faut rester
confinés chez vous et porter un masque
en présence d'autres personnes le numéro
qui s'affiche actuellement pour toutes
les informations complémentaires et
dernier conseil le ministre de la santé
olivier véran l'a rappelé éviter les
bises et des poignées de main
privilégiez des salutations simple
malgré la situation liée aux coronavirus
ces désistements de quatre équipes le
paris-nice est bien maintenue il
s'élancera ce dimanche depuis la commune
de plaisir le peloton partira demain de
la commune de chevreuse 11e édition pour
cette course cycliste dans les yvelines
11e édition consécutive les détails sur
la course avec michael et demi d'euros
et patrick jacques de dixmude
j moins 3 avant le départ du paris nice
cette course cycliste partira pour la
onzième année consécutive des yvelines
le peloton s'élancera depuis le village
départ du château de plaisir ce dimanche
8 mars pour une boucle de 154 km au
début on va faire une grande boucle on
va passer par pony des forêts montfort
l'amaury mais après on va on va tourner
vers crêpier affaires mots laurent
montet toutes les petites côtes et entre
chaque coup tu y as des longues lignes
droites qui a pas d'arbres il ya du vent
non
bon voilà on a on a été chercher la
difficulté le lendemain le lundi à midi
25 des parts depuis chevreuse communes
de moins de 6000 habitants
direction le loiret pour cette deuxième
étape une petite commune qui est mise en
avant donc nous on niveau aux structures
on a ceux des structures sont beaucoup
moins imposante prenez le départ et
d'aller à chevreux c'est parfait parce
que fâche heureux c'est un peu paradis
du vélo c'est un peu le cyclisme des
cyclistes qui roulent tous les dimanches
voir toute la semaine donc c'est un peu
l'histoire du vélo sur le plan sportif
des imprévus de dernière minute pour et
assombrir cette course au soleil
malgré la présence a annoncé les têtes
d'affiché comme julian alaphilippe
quatre équipes cyclistes ont déclaré
forfait à ce jour ineos endeuillée par
le décès de son directeur sportif
nicolas portal mais également miquel
tonnes et astana ultime emirates pour
cause de couronnes à virus cette édition
devrait tout de même être maintenue pour
l'instant il n'est pas question
d'annuler paris nice sauf si l'épidémie
biassette propage
bon on l'a pour l'instant comme
certaines grandes rencontres là ce jour
le paris nice a lieu le départ de cette
78e édition est donc pour l'instant
programmé ce dimanche 8 mars à 11h05
depuis plaisir le village départ sera
quant à lui installé devant le château à
partir du samedi 7 mars 9h
[Musique]
mais nous sommes à dix jours du premier
tour du scrutin des municipales les
électeurs ont rendez vous aux urnes le
dimanche 15 mars pour désigner leur
futur maire et si vous êtes absent ce
jour-là il est possible de recourir à
une procuration vous pouvez choisir une
personne pour voter en votre nom
celle ci doit être un électeur inscrit
dans la même commune que vous mais pas
nécessairement dans le même bureau de
vote est la démarche est à réaliser dans
un commissariat de police ou de
gendarmerie ou au tribunal et dont
dépend votre domicile ou votre lieu de
travail attention cette procuration doit
être établi le plus tôt possible pour
tenir compte des délais d'acheminement
toutes les précisions à retrouver sur le
site ce qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
l actualité de la campagne d'abord à
montigny le bretonneux il a commencé à
rassembler sa liste dès septembre 2019
l'ancien élu d'opposition pierre déjean
a complété sa candidature montini
solidarité à 2020 il a présenté ses
colistiers aux habitants hier à la salle
jacques-brel marie dania pichenot
dernière réunion publique avant les
urnes pour pierre déjean membres du
parti de gauche il présente sa liste
rassemblant différentes forces de la
gauche 41 ans représentant tous les
quartiers de la ville
nous avons je pense ce par rapport aux
autres disent l'éventail de d'âge des
plus jeunes le plus large puisque je
crois que notre jeune candidat qui est
une candidate a 19 ans et le plus âgé
doit avoir 74 les valeurs de gauche
comme ligne directrice de la liste et du
programme décliné en trois axes
principaux la solidarité pour plus
d'entrées d'entre les habitants
l'écologie avec un effort voulu sur la
consommation énergétique et la
démocratie nous avons acté que le
président de la commission de quartier
serait élu par ses pairs et non pas
nommés par la mairie en plus des trois
axes la culture étaient mis à l'honneur
durant cette soirée avec une réflexion
sur son pouvoir citoyen montigny
solidarité 2020 soit un changement pour
la commune administrée par la même
majorité depuis 1977 et l'élection de
nicolas à bouffe je pense que là il est
temps que la gauche revienne et qu'il
faut absolument agir pour reprendre
les actions sur nos vies et reprendre
nos vies en main pas simplement proposer
une consommation de la ville et de ses
services mme sy dire que voilà nous
sommes aussi là pour écouter aider les
gens et ne pas laisser seul dans son
coin pierre déjean et ses colistiers
vont poursuivre les rencontres avec les
habitants sur le terrain à travers
tractage et autres porte à porte dans la
commune de montigny le bretonneux deux
autres listes sont déclarés mais la
direction guyancourt maintenant rodolphe
baril à tête de liste d'ensemble
agissons pour du en cours a organisé un
meeting à la ferme de bel ébat est le
candidat présenté à cette occasion ses
colistiers ainsi que ses 84 engagement
pour la campagne dans son programme on
retrouve notamment des thématiques comme
le développement durable la démocratie
locale est également la tranquillité
publique on écoute
rodolphe baril au micro de michael elle
ni d'euros la sécurité en fait on en a
parlé également parce que ça fait partie
des thèmes des principaux thèmes qui
sont venus de la part des guyancourt toi
lorsqu'on les a interrogés lorsqu'on est
allé à leur rencontre
donc au niveau de la sécurité il ya
besoin d'un renforcement de la police
municipale puisque les effectifs sont
pas assez nombreux pour assurer des
amplitudes est suffisamment grande
également renforcement de la de tout le
réseau de caméras de vidéoprotection à
maurepas quatre candidats se sont
déclarés pour le scrutin le maire
sortant grégory à gary astier son
premier adjoint et roanne le gall ainsi
que les deux conseillers municipaux
d'opposition michel chapa et ismaïla
vannes présentation de ses candidats
avec mélanie poké maurepas 18 mille cinq
cent quarante trois habitants dans cette
commune quatre candidats se présentent
chargé de communication territoriale
grégory gars restiez s'engage en
politique à l'âge de 16 ans il est élu
maire de maurepas lors du scrutin en
2014 et fait basculer la vie la droite
la continuité d'avoir réveillé
autre belle endormie puisque maurepas
quant aux responsabilités avaient besoin
justement de changement d'avoir un
nouveau dynamisme ce que nous avons
engagé avec mon équipe et puis c'est la
volonté aussi de continuer à bien gérer
notre commune
on s'est désendetté de 30% depuis le
début du mandat autres candidats se
présentaient à maurepas michel chapa
ancien adjoint au maire avant 2014 ici
âge actuellement dans l'opposition il
n'a pas souhaité répondre à nos
questions au cours de cette campagne
proche et premier adjoint de grégory
gars restiez pendant six ans erwan le
gall présente sur cette mandature sa
propre liste il dirige depuis 2015 un
cabinet de conseil
faire des propositions pour la commune
avec des coûts financiers maîtrisé voilà
ça c'est un axe important il n'est pas
question d'aller partir de partir sur
des projets démesurés pour que les
impôts et la fiscalité des mort d'asia
s'enflamme ismaila vannes est à nouveau
tête de liste après 2014 le conseiller
municipal d'opposition se représente
ingénieur en électronique informatique
qu'il vit sur saint quentin en yvelines
depuis l'âge de 4 ans il s'engage dans
la jeunesse socialiste vers 16 ans
chaque projet dans un quartier doit être
au préalable discuter avec les habitants
des quartiers pour avoir leur avis bien
avant que ça passe en conseil municipal
donc pour faire cela ce que nous avons
pris comme décision dans notre projet
c'est de créer les comités de quartier
qui permettront d'avoir un référent par
quartier mais surtout de pouvoir
discuter des projets en amont dans les
yvelines pour ces municipales il faudra
également compter avec lutte ouvrière le
mouvement investi huit candidats dans le
département pour faire entendre le camp
des travailleurs de sont engagés dans
les communes de saint quentin en
yvelines olivier augustin tête de liste
aux clayes-sous-bois et patrick planque
en lice à trappes bonsoir à vous deux et
merci d'être avec moi sur ce plateau
alors déjà si on parle de l'objectif
global de lutte ouvrière de cette
campagne dans les yvelines c'est de
porter la voix des des difficultés des
salariés
ce sens on peut dire ça olivier brisse
et ses portes et surtout la colère la
colère du monde du travail et c'est pour
ça que notre liste
elle s'intitule le camp des travailleurs
et la colère bien s'exprime depuis pas
mal de temps avec les gilets jaunes là
depuis plusieurs plusieurs années depuis
deux ans avec toute la contestation
qu'il y a eu avec dans le monde
hospitalier dont avec les ehpad
mais aussi bien sûr contre la réforme
des cheminots et quads et des retraites
je veux dire et ça c'est quelque chose
que nous on veut continuer à apporter
toute cette colère la qui s'est exprimée
à travers donc nos listes et à travers
notre campagne pour les élections
municipales pour faire entendre le camp
des travailleurs c'est aussi forcément
la réforme du statut de cheminot vous
avez évoqué la réforme des retraites
médias vend effectivement cette cette
réforme
patrick l'encan quoi l'échelon communal
peut-il être intéressant justement pour
porter cette voie pourquoi se présenter
dans des élections municipales
enfin parce que ça pourrait être un
appui important aujourd'hui il y aurait
des élus communistes révolutionnaires de
nos listes dans les municipalités
ça serait d'abord pour
porter réellement le combat contre le
grand le grand capital contre les
grandes entreprises aujourd'hui qui
touchent des subventions qui licencient
et des élus municipaux permettrait
également d' organiser cette bagarre le
maire a ce pouvoir de pouvoir en tout
cas organiser la lutte
oui organisée dans les comités de
quartier dans des entreprises soutenir
là on a parlé de la grève contre la
réforme des retraites avec mes camarades
cheminots dont un certain nombre sont
sur les listes
on a fait plus de cinquante jours de
grève bien sûr que des élus dans une
municipalité aurait pu apporter
réellement une aide et pas uniquement
une aide organisé réellement la bagarre
la contestation
quitte à se mettre mal avec le
gouvernement avec avec le pouvoir
central
or si on s'intéresse à vos deux
candidatures respectives olivier auguste
ans il s'agit de votre troisième
candidature pour la mairie des clayes
sous bois après 2008 et 2014
lors des dernières élections en 2014
vous avez récolté 4 % des suffrages je
précise que vous êtes employé chez
renault à flins sur seine pourquoi être
de nouveau candidat pourquoi parce que
les problèmes ils sont encore plus
importants ils sont encore plus graves
que qu'avant quoi il puis les années
parce que les attaques contre le monde
du travail par cette bourgeoisie qui est
omniprésente et par l'ensemble du
patronat dans toutes les régions et y
compris dans la région
là où je me présente dans toutes ces
attaques là ils sont vraiment de plus en
plus dur alors la nécessité de se
défendre
pour nous les travailleurs elle est
encore plus urgente qu'avant et
effectivement il faut qu'on fasse
absolument le maximum pour regrouper
autour de nous tous les travailleurs qui
on a conscience que dans ce système là
on pourra pas s'en sortir si si on passe
pas à l'offensive avec leurs nécessités
particulières ou clayes-sous-bois on le
précise la maire sortante véronique côté
millard qui est élu depuis 2001 ne se
représentera pas pour cette élection
que ce soit aux clayes-sous-bois que ce
soit râble que ce soit à saint quentin
partout il ya nécessité que le monde du
travail
eh bien ils se fassent entendre ils
fassent entendre vraiment ses intérêts
et il est plus nécessaire à savoir ce
qui concerne le logement le transport et
bien sûr l'emploi parce que ça on n'en
parle pas beaucoup dans les élections
municipales et nous c'est vraiment ça
qu'on veut mettre en avant ses
nécessités là qui concerne pas tous les
habitants tous les travailleurs de
beaucoup de communes et y compris bien
sûr des clayes-sous-bois donc avec le 3
axes transports logement emploi patrick
lang de votre côté saisie de votre
première candidature des élections
municipales mais vous étiez est déjà
engagée en 2010 est aux côtés de
christine et gaz comme suppléant aux
législatives
donc c'était en 2017 dans la 11e
circonscription des yvelines là pourquoi
être tête de liste pour des municipales
pour les mêmes raisons pour faire porter
cette voie alors là la grève et le
mouvement de contestation contre la
réforme des retraites bien évidemment
influencé le choix et les décisions
vous savez quand on rencontre des
salariés qui sont comme sur la liste
aujourd'hui des femmes de ménage des
caristes des gens qui nous disent ah
vous êtes cheminots vous avez raison de
vous bagarrer parce que c'est pour
l'ensemble du monde du travail qui va
falloir se bagarrer c'est pour
l'ensemble ils vous faites une liste aux
municipales
ben moi je veux en être bassin on peut
pas on peut pas ne pas y aller on ne
peut pas ne pas accepter 7,7 par
reconnaissance mais en tout cas de se
mettre ensemble sur cette liste pour
faire entendre vraiment notre voie pour
faire entendre la voix des travailleurs
de ceux qui galèrent tous les matins
pour aller au boulot et qui font des
jobs comme ceux qui assurent la liste
aujourd'hui avec nous mais il était
d'autant plus important de la faire
entendre cette voix attrapons le précise
le maire guy malandain élu depuis 2001
ne se représentera également il sera
candidat pour ces municipales on le sait
attraper un grand héritage cheminots il
ya aussi une gare de triage à trappes
c'est aussi pour ça qu'il faut faire
entendre cette voix attrape alors oui ce
employés de la sncf j'ai oublié de le
préciser
oui mais pas depuis très longtemps j'ai
été embauché en 2014 à la sncf 1
précédemment travaillé dans l'automobile
à aulnay-sous-bois en 2013 j'ai été
licencié par le groupe psa c'est les
mêmes problèmes
c'est aujourd'hui les effectifs
diminuent les salaires et diminue
conçoit un cheminot qu'on soit dans
l'enseignement qu'on soit magasinier
cariste et où qu'on soit dans
l'automobile
oui il va falloir qu'on se il va falloir
qu'on s'organise qu'on se défende et ce
qui manque aujourd'hui clairement c'est
un parti un parti des travailleurs qui
organisent la riposte nécessaire pour
l'ensemble du monde du travail mais vos
listes respectives de 2 qui sont sont
elles constituent est justement un bon
camarade lundi de deux travailleurs
venant de tout horizon vraiment de tout
métier mais qu'ils ont
vraiment à coeur de faire entendre toute
cette colère là et qui partagent toutes
les bagarres toutes les difficultés et
bien sûr toutes les bagarres allende et
gilet jaune jusque au mouvement contre
la réforme des retraites et qui ont
vraiment accord pour reprendre cette
idée là c'est c'est qu'on s'arrête pas
simplement aux municipales mais qu'on
ait quand j'ai vu la bagarre et en vue
justement d'organiser ce qui manque
cruellement oui au monde du travail à
savoir un vrai parti communiste
révolutionnaire à un dernier mot un
petit tour de table pourquoi faut-il
voter pour la liste lutte ouvrière bat
pour toutes ces raisons pour nous
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment pour c'est
pas une liste on fera absolument aucune
promesse parce qu'on a absolument aucune
promesse à faire en tout cas la seule
promesse qu'on a c'est que oui on
continuera à travailler oui on
continuera à défendre le point de vue
des travailleurs et avec mes colistiers
et voilà et tous les gens qui sont sur
nos listes aujourd'hui c'est réellement
une liste de combat comme j'ai dit tout
à l'heure avec des gens qui ont envie
d'organiser les choses pour se défendre
pour se défendre contre ces attaques du
patronat du gouvernement un dernier mot
et parce que les attaques ne vont pas
cesser le patronat il y va vraiment à
fond comme on dit il ya l'histoire du
49-3 mais c'est le gouvernement qui
relaie aussi il ya sur toute la
politique du patronat et ben nous on a
49 3 raisons d'être encore plus en
colère et d'avoir encore plus envie et
bien de regrouper tous les travailleurs
conscients que dans cette société là on
n'aura pas le choix ça sera soit nous ou
soit soit la bourgeoisie kwh alors
autant que nous
on passe à l'offensive merci à vous de
tous les deux têtes de liste lutte
ouvrière faire entendre le camp des
travailleurs olivier augustin ou clé
souvent où son candidat également
stéphanie jamin anne-claire frémont
philippe guiguen et nicolas eu patrick
plan que vous cet attrape que vous êtes
engagés face à quatre autres listes
celle du maire sortant et guy malandain
d'autres magnats through dali rabais et
de bakou keita avec la liste citoyens en
action à voisins le bretonneux trois
candidats s'opposent pour devenir le
maire de la commune par mieux béatrice
pire à tête de liste avec vos voisins
avance une première campagne pour elle
qui organisait récemment une réunion
publique à la maison du maire en tech
manon vers le bas
après 27 années passées dans l'industrie
béatrice pierrât souhaite mettre à
profit de voisins-le-bretonneux ses
compétences de gestion de projet et
d'équipé
c'est une première campagne pour cette
cinquantenaire ça demande beaucoup
d'énergie pour mobiliser non seulement
les colistiers mais aussi la population
car je ne suis pas connu aujourd'hui
donc il faut que je fasse ma place dans
la ville lors de sa réunion publique
béatrice pire a exposé son programme aux
habitants parmi ses propositions un plan
vélo ou encore la création d'une maison
du savoir partagé afin de favoriser les
échanges intergénérationnels
il y a beaucoup de compétences dans la
ville notamment chez nos retraités et
nous souhaitons partager ses compétences
ses expériences dans une maison que nous
avons appelé aujourd'hui maison du
savoir partagé pour permettre aux plus
jeunes ou moins jeunes de profiter de
cette expérience de ses compétences
disponibles et on pouvoir ainsi avancé
la candidate est accompagné par jean h
élu d'opposition et anciennement tête de
liste pour voisins avec vous lors des
élections municipales en 2014
je considérais que moi je le devais
passer le témoin mais ne pas déserter et
donc que j'ai voulu qu'ils aient une
liste qui piloté par dès janvier nouveau
mais qui se retrouvent sur des valeurs
communes et nous avons construit un
programme sur trois piliers un premier
pilier sur les transition écologique et
énergétique à deux un pilier sur la
démocratie participative et à trois
piliers sur la solidarité la prochaine
réunion publique se déroule samedi 7
mars de 16h à 17h30 à la maison du maire
hanté de voisins-le-bretonneux la
nouvelle présentation de candidats cette
fois ci à villepreux les habitants
devront faire leur choix entre cinq
listes le maire sortant stéphane
mirambeau est celle de courage golgoht
lab de valérie bain de sylvie sedan
montel et de jean baptiste à monique est
le point avec aurélien ans pour
villepreux commune de 11000 151
habitants cinq candidats sont en lice
pour les municipales 2020 kourosh
golgoht l'aps chirurgien spécialiste en
orl habite à villepreux depuis 2002 à
titre personnel il est adhérent les
républicains parmi les
projet défendu par sa liste divers
droite la création d'une maison de santé
développer un centre de garde qui serait
qui sera ouvert de 8 heures du matin
jusqu'à minuit avec un minimum par
exemple radiologie hausse des plumes aux
nerfs et qu'on fasse le tri et le
traitement des gens sur place
c'est un service aux personnes âgées et
aux personnes en situation de handicap
aux enfants c'est primordial
merde villepreux depuis 2008 stéphane
mirambeau et candidat pour un troisième
mandat cadres supérieurs du secteur
privé il est également le quatrième
vice-président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en charge du
budget l'un des projets du candidat la
redynamisation du centre ville
on va pouvoir mettre des animations à
pouvoir mettre des marchés on va
redonner de la vie et on va pouvoir dans
une autre zone de ce même endroit
pouvoir tester des choses sur un tiers
lieu il ya beaucoup de gens de ce
village qui nous disent vous ne pensez
plus à nous il n'ya plus de commerces ya
pas de kaunas car n'y avait pas de
parking tête de liste d'agir avec vous
pour ville preuve valérie bain et
directrice d pad habite à villepreux
depuis 20 ans est adhérente à titre
personnel à la république en marche
parmi les projets mis en avant par cette
liste le développement de la culture
nous avons un théâtre de 600 places qui
ne fonctionne plus depuis douze ans et
donc on voudrait au moins qu'ils servent
aux associations et aux différents
groupes artistiques et serra qui sont
obligés de se produire à l'extérieur où
trouver des salles à l'extérieur
désormais conseillère municipale
d'opposition sylvie ce vent montait les
têtes de liste de tous pour villepreux
collaboratrice parlementaire elle est
également conseillère communautaire
déléguée à l'école innovantes
les enfants sont font partie de notre
programme
on va leur réserver une parcelle dans
les jardins potagers pour eux pour que
les centres de loisirs et les écoles
puissent avoir leur périmètre
mon objectif c'est que le foyer du
théâtre l'entrée du théâtre qu'un bel
espace en dehors de représentation sap
est un espace utilisé pour la jeunesse
ville président depuis 1996 jean
baptiste à monique et chef de cabinet
parlementaire
il est également délégué départemental
et porte-parole du modem dans les
yvelines la lys villepreux naturellement
à fait
parmi a fait de ses priorités
l'environnement et la défense du cadre
de vie de notre biodiversité
je pense notamment un objectif de zéro
artificialisation des sols que nous
inscrirons au pnud afin que nous
sanctuariserons nos espaces naturels et
puis nous voudront pousser la transition
écologique local de plus en plus au fur
et à mesure que des années passeront
enfin pour refermer cette page lue
nicipal ce jeudi soir et demain dernier
débat du premier tour diffusés sur tv 78
radio sensations pour ces deux dernières
émissions avec les candidats de
versailles ce soir débat numéro un à
versailles et demain vendredi ce sera le
débat numéro 2 c'est à chaque fois à 20h
sur notre chaîne ou sur la fréquence
c'est 80 18.4 pour nos confrères de
sensations yvelines et puis retour pour
terminer ce journal sur la journée
portes ouvertes qui s'est déroulée au
lycée d'hôtellerie et de tourisme de
guyancourt elle s'est déroulée samedi
dernier pour l'occasion la section du
bts tourisme qui regroupe 85 élèves a
choisi de mettre à l'honneur l'indonésie
au travers de stands animés de
dégustation ou encore de danse
traditionnelle écouter ses élèves et
leurs professeurs sur cette journée
interrogé par manou varaldo j'en aurai
faire plus stewart ou chef
dans un hôtel là je suis en première
année de bts tourisme collins et
hôtelier depuis en cours
et voilà aujourd'hui on présente un peu
ce à quoi ressemble nos cours comment
travaillent les matières et le rendu est
ici nous avons des cacahuètes au wasabi
on a également du sac et donc voilà qui
est plutôt connue et une petite bière
japonaise
on a eu vraiment des jeunes qui ont été
motivés comme un cahier des charges
qu'ils ont tenu un flux vraiment assez
dense toute la journée rythmée avec en
plus cette année on a eu la chance
d'avoir la participation donc de
l'office de tourisme a donné bien on a
eu donc la délégation indienne qui est
venu nous rencontrer à disposition donc
des visiteurs donc aussi nos étudiants
pour présenter cette belle destination
c'est la fin de ce journal dans un
instant nouveau numéro du 7-8 loisirs
pour être au fait de quelques idées de
sorties à faire ce week-end dans les
yvelines belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
oh